ladies and gentlemen we are going to
watch today episode 9 the rise of
skywalker starring visions this is
called a what is this a [ __ ] in
a cocking
there's something blocking the screen
there was a thing blocking it
i know how to read guys listen it's the
final episode
hit that like button if you like people
uh if you don't like people you can
still hit the like button and uh full
length watch alongs where you sync up
with the time coder over at our patreon
page we cover a lot of crap over there
too so much crap with ratchet highlights
and watch alongs included hey prothomer
jayden thanks for editing this down for
us all right guys let's watch a cook
coop
oh damn
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
oh cool going back to canto bite
that white saber oh no it's not okay
oh
[Music]
[Music]
who would have thought there'd be a sith
hidden among the royal family
is that
henry golding oh my god i think you're
right
most charming voice in the galaxy
i'm not sure i will just go this way
lady misa who is your strange friend
can i travel all the way here by himself
seems kind of suspicious
from what i can tell you can't seem to
fight i see did i judge my appearances
do they
we're not strong fighters
i like him why do we need guys to lead
us back to your palace i am in exile and
now cannot even get close to the palace
what fascinating animation well they're
searching for you
but they better not get in the way
no they will
you're not scared are you jedi it's a
protection song against evil spirits
he really wants to whip this sith lord's
ass
we want to go through all this
[Laughter]
there's a path across the mountain we
can't do that there's a reason why they
call the area the place of the gods
because no one who has entered has ever
recruited
impossible
i'll add 300 credits
that's just
500.
deal
[Laughter]
oh whoa cool boy
we have to go back
it's hopeless it's his destiny to die
this is divine punishment nothing is
pre-tested i'll find you later
[Laughter]
oh
i'm fine
what's going on with his head
he's having
visions
oh
your father is making a fuss that his
princess has disappeared
he's just overreacting why are you out
there really
just thinking about bringing stability
and peace to this world and what it
would take to do it
that is so hot
i've thought about it too about what i
can do also about what i can't what was
your conclusion well well
did you think that by bringing your jedi
you'd be able to avenge your pitiful
father
you are to leave this planet right now
and never return is this a taste of that
jedi benevolence
keeping his hat on
you have talent but you lack technique
oh hell no
he was always going to die because it
was written
there is nothing that has not been fated
[Music]
go to the dark side
no
i have to go
you've been having a nightmare recently
a vision of someone being killed
repeatedly if you go he will be tempted
and it will cloud your judgment
if it comes to that understand i won't
be able to save you
no
it's not
no it's really red
oh
premonition who did he just kill
no
without power you can change nothing
with you by my side we will be able to
move together and we will bring order to
the galaxy we can protect your precious
mesa as well protect her she's dead
why don't we try to save lisa together
oh
clever
do it
come to the dark side
please
help me save her i love how much of a
character the music is
ah
is that oh he gave it
oh [ __ ] well they could do that now what
did you do
shall we go
oh
dude what a great soundtrack yeah
wow oh
i love this
oh ho ho ho no
oh that was awesome
a plus i love that one a lot yeah
henry golding
got it
well done
what a great soundtrack
felt like one song they better yeah i
don't know the kind of music that is but
i liken it to jazz
i mean yeah i i don't know what the
tendency improvising yeah
that's very like yeah reform and
percussive yeah and these just these
different like
repetitive tones i love the parallels
here between anakin and
palpatine oh don't tell me you guys
didn't pick up on that shiznit yeah and
hey even your boy george takei was in
this one
do i have like a
thing for george takei you in one of the
previous episodes you were like is it
george decay we were like i don't know
but one thing's like a gazillion
voiceovers
he's one of the most recognized
i'm george
takei i i don't know i i guess i didn't
know which character he was you're poor
the two guys he's one of the two leads i
don't know
sorry never mind i i know you you don't
care at all about george tk i'll never
think of my level of investment
[Music]
let's talk about it i'm pulling mike's
over
yeah so like this guy was like anakin
and uh and uh in order to save uh padme
who's dying
uh he has to join with the person he's
been trying to you know uh big lady he
had a big lady like palpatine's a big
lady
big bad ass lady with red eyes
and so because the whole goal is to save
except he actually saves his woman from
dying
because he kept having visions of her
dying and just like how he was having
visions of her dying yeah she didn't
know his visions of her dying that hurt
but that was
her dying in his visions it was in his
star wars visions yes
i know you really wanted them hoping for
an opportunity
since the series began
to make that joke
that was great that was a that was a
really great one i was a little thrown
off by the animation at first when i was
looking at the girl's eyebrows
it moved like like a water bed
yes yeah and i loved how um this is an
interesting fluidity is the word not
lucid uh
i want to say stream like with the way
the animation was yeah there's something
very alive about and this one elements
were alive yeah
this one out of all of them felt perhaps
the most like hand crafted to me like
yes
because because the more you dive into
yeah like hand-drawn animation and stuff
like that the more those motions and
things come to life and like the little
nuances of even just jitters of the
inconsistencies like the tiny tiny
inconsistencies of drawing like
contribute to that yeah and uh
yeah yeah i thought the
the way they captured the the elements
of their travels made that more engaging
because because of the fact of how
it felt like everything was alive around
them i mean like the most obvious thing
you can point to is like when they're
being
in the in the rainstorm they're going
through yeah they're so [ __ ] like wet
heavy and
desolated yeah it just looks like
rain pouring down is like sharp almost
this is how hard and nasty it is yeah
yeah like that that's like the most
obvious part of when they're montaging
through and then also like the to me
uh i i would say this is my favorite
music only be and the music's been
pretty great on this series overall but
it's probably my favorite because of the
fact that it feels like a character
uh here more than anywhere and any of
the other episodes like you get the vibe
that there's the like the the group i
don't i don't know what kind of music
you would call that
japanese thingy japanese thingy japanese
thingy music
spotify it's like a japanese thingy some
type of drum circle yes tell tell my
dumb american brain down below
uh
what kind what style of music that is
you know because yeah i i love i love
that kind of music but i loved how it
just felt like one track
throughout
that was um
like the the way the notes were going
were
uh in tune with the way the scenes were
progressing or the character
uh going downhill
so he was basically haunted by
the vision of what would ultimately
change him
yeah the premonition
that's too bad man very much too bad
very much too bad
i love how the sith lord lady was like
this big ass [ __ ] that's right man [ __ ]
you
big
i got the dark side all up in me i could
take you out with my bare hands but i'm
gonna do with my lightsaber and i'll
make you i'm gonna do it one better i'm
gonna make you my apprentice
she's like she's she's like a a truly
menacing version of
that joke in in in cartoons
i'm drawn with all the same dimensions
as like a hulking boy character and i
have a deep voice but i'm a lady pick on
the main character
intimidating and even right down to like
it wasn't my favorite lightsaber fight
uh but
i love how you can track the motion of
the lightsaber
again yeah you can really feel like the
the first time i smoked
the ghost trail
yeah the ghost trails of the animation
and that that does feel like you're
watching like yeah a couple extra static
frames of the glowing lightsaber as it
moves yeah yeah it was great mm-hmm it's
great and even that color change at the
end to just like all red well i liked
watching him too because he was uh he
was the kind of jedi that was different
than the other jedi we've been hanging
out with
who are very
wise you know they've been a jedi for a
long time and they're they're uh they've
aged and here he's kind of like uh like
a wolverine he's very just aggressive
and moody and grunty and impatient
yeah he's crazy
i think that's what made it believable
because they did a good job on using the
flashbacks to show the history with him
and the
female protagonists you know i know
character names very well queen amidala
etc yeah showing the um showing the
flashbacks there because
uh
with his character here you see
like oh yeah this guy could definitely
turn to the dark side yeah
he seems like he's a few feet away he
said he is all the time already
seems like the most dour jedi imaginable
yeah
and uh i like that i i i thought the
term was really cool and it would have
it makes it so much more of a a rich
cool like tragic tale yeah of the fall
of a jedi yeah um
in in this short encompass like
what is the word i'm looking for
not haiku
i don't know like an elegy or what what
are you trying to describe let's
workshop this we can get to the bottom
it's something that's like a poetic
short film
like a mood piece
no that's not good or not that's not
good enough
it's a it's a poetic short film i mean
even down to hold on i'm gonna google
i'm gonna google a translation here
because akka means red so does kiri mean
like life is like because it's like the
direct
uh you know tr
transition into oh fog red fog there you
go
but they are a compa and they're
they're surrounded by
after he kills that is that i thought
when you see the way they're coming
after him
it's like bertha is just like growing
yes that's her name yeah versus just her
name now throwing these people and he's
just like ah and he's like walking like
zombies yeah it's like what the hell is
going on here so it seemed like she was
who was she she was so powerful i know i
hope they do another visions and pick
this up they fought for five seconds and
she's like you're done you're you can't
come on i can help you come on henry
golding did a great job he did he was
very especially for a lot of henry
golding
yeah i know i was gonna say you picked
that up right straight away
quicker than i picked up george takei
but yeah i really liked him and
especially for as laconic like as as
little the character speaks like you've
got to make it count you also got to be
able to sell this character's he speaks
quite a bit
yeah but it's not it's
it's one of those where it's like even
though
i guess what i'm trying to say is like
his lines aren't super duper flashy
and uh and i feel like you know there
are other characters who do get to kind
of like banter more and stuff like that
but i thought it had a lot of presence
and you could tell like the same way
like david harbor not quite on that same
degree but the same way you could feel
it's like very close to the mic and it's
very much like in the mood yeah you know
like i thought yeah did a really nice
job transporting to that place vocally
well it's got to have the right level
where yeah he's a little bit moody but
you got to feel that he cares yeah and
there's some urgency
yeah i even liked uh scully and
hitchcock that's right yeah
hey you know they proved their worth for
an extra 500 credits i enjoyed them yeah
and i and i uh too i mean i i like this
one a lot yeah i would i
i would say
for sure the out of nine the four that
stand out the most to me are one
i'm gonna get crap for not putting twins
on here
let's say one okay
five was the ninth jedi
but i remember the title better than i
remember yeah
so because i believe four was the uh the
bride the village bride
and then uh what was the one with david
harbor uh that was
uh the red guardian
uh this one was akakiri i i
might so clearly i have a very specific
taste for what i wanted out of this yeah
yeah which is i watered a samurai shogun
a samurai shogun not as much plot
oriented dial i thought this one did a
really great job of i think this was a
nice capper because even though the last
two do end on harsher notes this one
felt like i really did just see like i
think you're you're on the money with
something that i too cannot quite
describe with
it does feel like i witnessed like a
short movie
that had all the flavors and it was
really transportive and it was like
really alive and and all of the elements
like once i start zeroing in on one all
the others come to high relief so it's
like well it could be the music or it
could be this and yeah it just feels
like a real actual film and i think the
way that they chose to dis uh
the way they chose to orient the
dialogue versus the action like it's a
very visual
story and a very tone-oriented story
and i think that the best of this series
has often wound up in that place where
the dialogue isn't so much catching you
up on a bunch of exposition and stuff
like that it's more letting you bask in
the mood and the even pov at times the
head space of like this vision that
keeps coming into this guy's head
and so yeah it's like it really is a
striking little it feels like a piece
you have like an individual piece that
you would look at yeah i'd love to watch
this one in japanese i actually like to
go back and watch them all in japanese
big tv is what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
watch some more we have a bigger screen
now than when we watched like snyder but
now we're just always gonna be longing
for a bigger tv screen with no lights on
there's got to be a way to do that
build a camera into the top of the tv
where we can't see it and then rig up
some kind of night vision system that
cuts the difference and still has like
human color and then we're set
all right guys well star wars visions i
quite enjoyed this this was a great ride
and i hope they do this annually i would
i would absolutely love if they did this
i like this more than bad batch
this this feels very unique and and
special
in a in a
unique and special way yeah he said
eloquently repeating himself
sarcastically setting up the next verse
all right we'll see you guys
[Music]
you